by way of advice
you know to young filmmakers
how to film something that
um
is recognized
by the world in some way i would say you
know first off learn your craft
right um because i think craft is
incredibly foundational right to
creating
a powerful story and sorry to interrupt
but when you say craft do you mean just
the raw technical the director of
photography like the filming aspect is
it the storytelling is it the axe is the
whole thing i think craft is more than
just knowing how to push record on a
camera or what limbs to use right that's
part of it right
but i i think um
at least in non-fiction
you know i'm i'm a product
to some extent of
having to know how to do it all
right having to teach myself how to do
it all because i didn't go to film
school you know um
but i became so
um enamored of telling stories through a
camera what was the leap by the way from
theater to
storyteller oh i just had needed an
extra class in grad school i was in a
mfa directing class and i needed an
extra class and i just sort of like
talked my way into a television
directing class
and fell in love with it and the actor
became the director yeah yeah
well yeah i mean i wasn't an actor but
but i i had to act i had to know the
craft of acting because i was in the
theater you know too did you love it
though did you love
did you love theater yeah
um the first yeah the as an
undergraduate yeah but then i learned
pretty quickly that i was pretty bad at
it
um or at least not very good um and that
my skills lay elsewhere uh
in more sort of behind the scenes and
shaping a story when you started
you know taking a class but also telling
stories as a director did you
quickly
realize that you're pretty good at this
or was it a grind
that's a good question max um i think
i definitely knew right away
that it was more my wheelhouse right and
and i think part of that was because i
um
i i grew up in
sort of a world of imagination
um and i think that active imagination
as a child
really lent itself well to the skill set
that a director needs
right
to shape story to shape narrative to
shape performances so i think it was a
much more natural fit for me was i
excellent at the beginning heck no no
you know i think few people are
but i learned where was the biggest
struggle for you is it so your
imagination clearly was uh
something that you worked on for a
lifetime
so i'm sure that was pretty strong books
came from books books
but the actual conversion of the amount
just says shape the story
where was the skill most lacking in the
shaping of the story initially technical
side just technically yeah i'd like you
know because i taught myself everything
right what kind of microphone should i
use right what kind of camera what does
this lens do what's that lens do i
didn't know any of that and so i
essentially was i have been self-taught
technically how do you get good
technically would you say when you're
self-taught doing it over and over again
and what kind of stories were you
telling like uh like i began shooting
local commercials um for for for money
for money yeah yeah actually doing
professional projects yeah yeah and so i
kind of learned on the job as i did it
how many hobby projects did you do just
for the hell of it were you trying to
focus on the professional i was trying
to make money right right out of grad
school just to pay the rent and that
that you know that's a forcing function
to
i mean i i personally love having my
back to the wall or financially you're
screwed
to succeed
so that's nice uh i mean i lived out the
trunk of my car for a couple years after
grad school just freelancing you know
just like but but that couple years
really helped me learn fast because i
had to learn fast you know so i did a
couple
i did a couple voyages around the world
for this group called semester at sea
that has a floating university that
where they go out three and a half
months at a time with the with about 500
college level students and about 35
professors and so you're shooting every
day for three and a half months in like
nine different countries and so
that really was like instrumental to me
becoming a pretty good camera person
pretty quickly and you're doing most of
the work yourself one man one man bad
yeah the second the second uh voyage i
at least had an editor with me yeah but
i was shooting everything yeah what's
the perfect team is it two people
for for non-fiction
asking for a friend yeah i'm kind of
interested in some storytelling not of
the level
and the sophistication that you're doing
but more i think you have to allow the
story to dictate what the size of the
film should be for these small human
rights talks i do i think two or three
you know it means you work your butt off
right because you're doing everything
right but it allows you to tell intimate
stories and have that access i i'm doing
a film this summer that's a that's a
scripted piece where we'll probably have
25 crew people oh wow you know so it's a
completely different different endeavor
altogether but doing it yourself
what do you think about that
even though you i you have that trillion
dollars
oh i have that trillion dollars again
sweet you can write that check before i
leave yeah i will okay great
i've never seen a check for that big
it'll be interesting how many zeros is
that i read them so often
[Laughter]
i've lost track
or the united states government sure as
heck writes them often okay anyway um i
mean like is there an argument can you
steal man the case for a single person
you know not for me um not for me
and and here's
why um
what i found
is that
by by being a team of two
filming with a field producer by two
people filming
um
it allows
us to double our footage
first off right so we have twice as much
footage in the time we're filming to
come back with as opposed to one person
filming so you're each
manning a camera yeah constantly
and how much how much uh sorry to keep
interrupting how much interaction
interplay there
sometimes the director of photography is
in another room
filming a different scene if it makes
sense sometimes we're cross shooting in
the same room yeah right it just depends
on the needs of the moment
so so we come back with double footage
is one thing but as a director so that's
you know and given how access is some
sometimes shaped by the events so that
we can only something you know
in lifeboat for example you know a
rescue operation may only happen three
three days right so you want as much
footage as you can but the other piece
of it that's really critical for me i
found is that by having another human
being i'm filming with who i'm
co-shooting with it frees me up as a
director to not always have to be
shooting either i can do all the other
work to build relationships right to
have side conversations with people to
to sort out the right way to tell a
story right or to transfer footage
knowing that the director of photography
is still filming during all that so it
frees me up to think of a as a director
rather than just an image
acquirer yeah because there's also i
don't know how distracting is you've
obviously done it for years but setting
stuff up
it uh
pre-act it it
preoccupies your mind like pressing the
record button yeah and like framing
stuff and all that that still that takes
up some part of your mind where you
can't think freely that's my choice
right that's how i work best that said
the caveat there would be that's not the
only way to do it obviously right like
one of my favorite documentary time
documentaries of all time
um is a documentary called a woman
captured shot in hungary
uh by a single filmmaker with a single
camera with a single lens right
and it's brilliant
and powerful and moving
and
interventional
it's it's incredible filmmaking and it
was a single human being who created
that film with with um with a
collaborator or subject so it can be
done it's just not how i work best yeah
how much personally with the other
person
how important is the relationship with
them
outside of the filming like uh with the
director of photography director
photographers say like
how much
drinking and if you don't drink whatever
the equivalent of that is do you have to
do together
how much soul-searching or is it more
like two surgeons getting together is it
is it surgeons or is it a jazz band well
it could be either right hopefully not
at the same time though because i don't
think surgeons and jesus fans go well
together
probably they're both good they're both
good with fingers
exactly but i'd rather maybe not playing
jazz while they operate on me yeah um
but but i think um
for me um i think there are moments of
both but usually not at the same time
right there are surgical moments where
the moment is so pressing you really
have to be
that task driven right to capture as
thoroughly as possible whatever's
unfolding right
but i think there's other times where
you do improvise like jazz right and
where where you have a lot of choices
ahead of you and and you're doing it
maybe a dance with the other camera
person right in order to capture a scene
as creatively and fully as possible
during a fixed duration
how much you said shaping because it is
non-fiction
but i feel like there's so many ways to
tell the same non-fiction that it's
borderline on fiction
yeah this is well
it's storytelling
it
and
how much shaping
do you see yourself as as doing
like how important is your role how you
tell the story
um
i suppose the question i'm asking is how
many ways can you really screw this up
every day you can screw it up
um i mean that's really the
what i think what you're asking about is
really the ethos of documentary
filmmaking right i i allow a lot of
things to guide my choices um
one of them being
am i being fair
right not balanced right but i am i
being fair
to what i'm witnessing does the camera
capturing in a fair way the truth
of the reality some fundamentals and it
also speaks to consent right um am i
being fair in a sense of conce do i have
active consent in this moment right
regardless whether i have a signed piece
of paper i always find some way to
document it whether it's just direct
address to camera or you know
um a translated release so there's
actually that's an interesting little so
they they say something to the camera
that they consent or they sign the thing
yeah so for example you know i think the
large you know broadcast companies have
this formalized process where they
present a piece of paper
right yes and
the subject reads it and they sign it
and then you have permission and that's
irrevocable right so it'll hold up in
court
that's not how i operate right and so
um
it's it's just
for example that doesn't work if
someone's illiterate and can't read that
piece of paper right right what if they
don't know how to sign their name right
so instead you have to have a
conversation
ask questions have them ask questions
come to a complete understanding before
you even know whether they understand
what you're asking right and then in
that case if someone's illiterate then
you have that conversation you sit down
and it takes a long time sometimes but
you have to do it and then if they still
want to participate and they give you
their consent you know they can't sign a
piece of paper right so then you just do
in their native language right direct
consent to camera in their language
interesting but also you're speaking to
the consent that's
just a human placing trust in you yeah
you make a connection like this that's
the most important concern right yeah i
hate papers
i hate papers
and lawyers
because they they exactly for that
reason yeah okay great but
you should be focusing on the human
connection that leads to the trust to
the like real consent and consent day to
day minute to minute because that can
change absolutely and it does change
you